Computadores quânticos são projetados para resolver problemas que não podem ser tratados
por computadores clássicos —
como encontrar os materiais certos para viabilizar
a captura de carbono para realmente
enfrentar a mudança climática, para desenvolver
fertilizantes mais eficientes que
não prejudiquem a terra, mas também mantenham
a cadeia de abastecimento alimentar que precisamos para alimentar o mundo.
Também há questões fundamentais sobre como nosso universo
está estruturado e como a matéria se comporta no nível atômico
e subatômico que precisamos entender.
É a próxima fronteira.
Vamos falar de uma área em que pesquisas já estão em andamento:
a busca por novas baterias.
As baterias transformaram nossas vidas ao nos permitir carregar
computadores e smartphones.
Mas há mais a ser feito — as baterias são fundamentais
para o nosso futuro de energia limpa,
seja para alimentar carros elétricos ou realmente
impulsionar a energia renovável.
Precisamos de uma química fundamentalmente diferente
para criar as baterias
do futuro. A computação quântica
nos permitiria observar o interior da bateria de forma eficaz
durante suas reações muito complexas, para nos ajudar a
pensar em novos materiais
e na estrutura das baterias que serão necessárias
para alimentar a próxima geração de dispositivos.
Como chegamos lá? Construindo os dispositivos quânticos mais avançados do mundo
e uma plataforma de desenvolvimento,
tornando tudo isso disponível para o mundo.
Somente trabalhando juntos agora
vamos conseguir resolver os problemas que enfrentaremos
juntos no futuro.